ice is cool it covers tens of millions
of square miles of the Earth's surface
its strong enough to carve out entire
continents but increasingly threatened
by humans we studied it for centuries in
the most inhospitable places on earth
and the story of ice is a story of
science scientists and sacrifice now I'm
no expert on ice but I know a guy who is
this is Tom Tom is a gravel monkey for
his ph.d he studied glaciers Gigaton
structures of ice that carve out valleys
and shape landscapes Tom and I are
combining our forces to create an
educational series all about ice it's
physics effect on the climate and
history released every week on this
channel through interviews lecture
segments and demonstrations we really
hope to give you a thorough introduction
to ice on Earth to the cryosphere we'll
be kicking off next week with the story
of where water on earth came from the
science of freezing and taking a trip to
the archives of the Scott Polar Research
Institute in Cambridge I really hope
that you join us to this journey over
the next 10 weeks we've got some
fantastically exciting stuff planned and
I'm really proud of what Tom and I have
achieved with this series so to make
sure that you don't miss out if you're
not already subscribed to this channel
and click the bell down there to get
notifications when new episodes go live
I'm really looking forward to seeing you
and teaching of our ice next week in
crash course cryosphere
[Music]
[Music]